we're here with the hgtv stars mike
jackson and egypt sherrod
and we're also here
with simone one of our viewers who
wanted mike and egypt's help creating a
mud room on a budget which we did over
there and it is absolutely stunning and
now egypt you're gonna show us a
brilliant diy hack to organize shoes for
less than a hundred dollars what is it
so we have created shoe storage cubbies
out of pvc pipes wow literally six inch
pvc pipes wrap them creatively with
wallpaper again stick on wallpaper to
give you this look what's fantastic
about it is you know whether you're in
an apartment or you're in a big house no
one can ever have enough storage so you
can make this as large as you want just
add more as small as you want it's high
you can even do abstract designs with it
because look at this
they don't move
um how do you do this mike did you
pre-buy
cut pvc how do i approach this
mwahahaha did you see you want to
partake in this yes come on out okay all
right
your faces you're like getting it
just okay so you take that that's gonna
be yours right this is going to be mine
pvc usually comes pre-cut right usually
at 24 inches so at your big box so you
can have them cut it for you to the size
that you need now we have some sandpaper
here because when they cut it the edges
are jagged so you want to sand that down
so it's nice and smooth okay okay
so
pvc your wallpaper yes it's peeling
stick so grab your corner put that down
oh build this off let's get it get an
edge let's see if she can do it with her
nails let's see if you can do it now i'm
leaving you you got this oh this is this
wait just a second time off okay oh [ __ ]
by the way
no i got my really crowded one secondly
i'm the one that does the wallpaper but
the funny thing was let you do this
today
you see what happens when you move too
fast we weren't supposed to take the
paper all the way off i was okay because
now you're gonna fumble a little bit but
go ahead see that's that's what you
that's what you get from me
so anyway put your piece down take your
pvc piece down now mine you can put any
type of wallpaper on there make sure
it's peeling stick for your design
aspect okay you ready you see thank you
ladies it's going to stick let's grab an
edge
at home it's a lot easier you don't need
four people
really the key is i did these three
though you
you started first
and you peel back the underlayment and
roll back see how you're rolling now oh
yes and then it makes it look at that
look at that beautiful you got it okay
so if you look
drill
simone we left this gap on purpose
because we don't want the glue
or double-sided tape sticking to the
wallpaper because it can rip the
wallpaper off and then they won't be
able to stick to each other properly
okay cool beans
so the tape would go here and then you
would just stick them together these are
already stuck together and then we would
build on top of each other as such so
simone we want to send you home with a
thousand dollar gift card so you can get
everything how you see fit to your style
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and watch them compete on rock the block
one of my very favorite shows ever on
hdtv
[Music]